yo it's the bullet head podcast
with special guests my guy man mean yes
sir
appreciate you having me bro oh good man
so uh for people who don't know who you
are man you've been
killing [ __ ] for a long time you uh what
a few years ago you
were doing a song every week that's
right that's a lot that's when i met you
right right um
yeah i did i mean mondays yeah me
mondays that's what i called it so
you know how people consume music
nowadays man i felt like
something wasn't working for me you know
i'm saying i kept dropping projects you
know you work
on a project for a [ __ ] year six
months and then people are over it in
like two weeks you know i'm saying
for sure so i had to do something to
make my presence felt more and uh
so i did the series i called it mean
mondays 52 songs in 52 weeks for the
whole year
actually i continued past the year
another like three months so i wasn't
really like 64 or something you know i'm
saying but christ
but what that did is um it just created
this online presence you know what i'm
saying
a lot of doors open a lot of people
started reaching out
kind of got the ball rolling to where we
had now you know um
talk about obviously
i cause you've you've been like you've
been on tours recently
with uh chris webby and yup and burner
um and you've you're kind of like
are you the biggest armenian rapper for
sure
for sure right yes for sure yeah i could
probably say that yeah i'm definitely
you know the first for my for my
community to do it on this level you
know what i'm saying there's always men
you know kids on a street level trying
to you know trying to do it
even when i started like over 10 years
ago you know what i'm saying but like
nobody really stuck to it you know
yeah was it like hard to get embraced by
your community or was that the easy part
no i mean in in the beginning it was
like
both armenians and non-armenians are
like
why is this armenian god happen what i'm
saying because it's just so different
but you know the whole i i feel like
hip-hop as a whole just kind of been
evolving and
more accepting of different you know
different ethnicities and stuff so like
yeah then i became that guy in my
community you know what i'm saying and
they embrace me and also like when they
heard me they're like okay this guy is
not like
like he can really rap like this is a
real hip-hop artist yeah i'm saying like
i'm not doing it for
armenians or you know what i'm saying
like i'm just trying to compete with
everybody you're just a dope rapper who
happens to be armenian armenian you know
what i'm saying and
so then they really embraced me and
since then like my people been having my
back
like the armenian community is pretty
big like of course we are in la but like
worldwide
they [ __ ] with me just off the strength
of that before these tours we just
mentioned
like i've been touring you know small
runs in like europe
canada east to west coast you know what
i'm saying so shout out to my people you
know
um you i know that you're a big i know
you
so you're so you're a huge naz fan huge
eminem guy
yup um you
put out a song kind of as an homage to
nas
yeah right to both of them so tanas and
eminem yeah
and uh you told me recently that now's
heard the song
yeah i haven't really told this to
anybody but uh
tell the story man so what happened was
this was 2016. so when you put the song
out
when i put i put this mixtape out so
this was like a year like things just
were just not going well you know what
i'm saying it was right before i did the
whole me monday's thing right
and um just like you know just being a
fan i you know i just wanted to rap over
those beats
so i just did a mixtape called nas and m
it was all their beats you know what i'm
saying
but then one specific song i called it
letter to the king which was like an
actual tribute
you know what i'm saying like the last
song on the tape first verse i'm talking
in nas
second verse i'm talking to m and i did
it over the renegade beat oh fire okay
um
so and a song came on fire like a lot of
like two dope boys and
pops like everybody posted about it like
yo the [ __ ] is incredible you know what
i mean
so then we decided to [ __ ] go to
queens bridge and go into detroit and
actually shoot a video for it
and kind of go all out with it you know
what i'm saying and that was that
so that was in 2016 like end of 2016 and
then recently just like
last year so like a good three years
later
i get a facetime out of nowhere and it's
[ __ ] nice
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying and the reason i did not
m by the way is cause like i mean they
were my favorite rappers like kind of
growing up and when i started doing this
you know so i always say like if i had
to pick
my two biggest influences would be nas
in them of course there's more you know
right
right so yeah and it was [ __ ] nausea
you know i'm saying he's like yo bro i
just heard that song
and i'm like which song and that moment
cause it's been like a few years
i didn't realize and i'm all excited
like what the [ __ ] i'm saying like nah
is calling me
and um he's like yo the one you did for
me and m you know what i'm saying
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm so happy you
finally heard it he's like nah that [ __ ]
did something to me bro you know what i
mean and he touched his
you know i mean yeah touching his chest
and then we just kind of like chopped it
up about what i got going on i'm working
on a solo project with scott's storage
and this and this and that
um and three days later we was in the
studio you know what i'm saying so even
nas
you went from making a whole project
dedicated partly to knives to getting in
the studio with him
yeah crazy what was that like being in
the studio happiest day in my life
you guys cut a record together we did uh
and the only reason i'm saying this
because i kind of posted on social media
already but
i would want to come back when when we
dropped the regular really talk about it
you know what i'm saying
because i haven't really talked about
this i kind of avoid this question but
yes we have a song and it's [ __ ]
crazy what was the reason the reason i
say
it's the happiest day in my life is not
just because i was in the studio with
nas but
the song came out so perfect you know
as far as like what i would envision
that i would want to do with nas it just
that's the important together you did a
song with knives and it could have been
you know
what i'm saying because also i wasn't
ready for it it's not like i expected it
and i had a record ready and i was like
yo
get on this you know what i'm saying it
was like three days later and then you
know since i was working with scott like
scott he does everything on the spot you
know what i'm saying like he doesn't
like send you a bunch of beats right you
pick from it like
you go into the session it starts with a
conversation like what kind of record
you want to do
and then he starts making the beat on
the spot you know what i'm saying that's
the same thing so
i went to the studio with scott um at
scott's house maybe a couple hours
before nas came
like nah said he'll be there like let's
say five o'clock right so i went to
scott's like at two or three
and we [ __ ] created the beat but he
was in like honestly i never seen scott
that excited either you know what i'm
saying like
he's obviously worked with everybody but
he was [ __ ] excited so
he [ __ ] murdered it in like 20
minutes and i started kind of
brainstorming ideas by the time nas came
i felt like comfortable like okay we got
him so you recorded this at scott
storch's house yep
hey what your relationship with scott
stewart how did that start
um crying it through
through burner be real steve lobel so
yeah i'm dropping an album with
burner like tonight rightly is probably
it'll be out already it'll be out
so i got a collab album with burner um
it's called the warning on god was the
first
first single with davies um you know
that's kind of like a family i've been
knowing steve lobel for a long time
and um [ __ ] already like maybe two or
three years ago
i went in and did one song with scott
you know what i'm saying okay
um so and that was that was amazing that
was through steve lobel that was our
introduction you know what i'm saying
and then when i linked with be real and
i linked with burner
and they're kind of like a family and
their business partner is all like
armenian
right right right not all but they have
like something you have somebody named
business partners dispensaries and they
were all like yo
you know army we've been your biggest
[ __ ] fan for so many years
you know what i'm saying um they're like
yo we've been following you from the
beginning they started telling me all
the first first [ __ ] that i did and like
so you know they kind of were like the
unofficial stamp
you know what i'm saying to burner be
real was already like
you know really like bigging me up so
that's kind of how i got reintroduced to
scott like yo this is not just some
independent rapper trying to like he's
really that dude in our community
right and scott was already [ __ ] with
it so then we got
we linked back together and we ended up
working on a whole project
which we still working on but we're like
80. i was going to say like 80 90
whole project with burner and a whole
project with scott storch i'm blessed
bro song with knives
[ __ ] blessings i know you got a lot
of other big features that you're
sitting on i'm [ __ ] blessed bro
a lot of doors been opening for me
lately a lot of
big features yo it's crazy because like
i do feel like uh like when i think of
you like
i think of like a lyrical you know beast
right like
yeah but i know some of the features
that you're sitting on are with
rappers that might be a little
unexpected
now as you would expect absolutely but
i'll tell you like this like when i did
that me mondays thing
and i dropped like all these songs like
like you said i've always been like a
spitter i've always been a good like
mc like lyricist that was always my
thing when i started rapping i just want
to outrap everybody
right alphabet anybody out challenge me
on the track out rat you know what i
mean like
but then i kind of turned into more of a
real artist you know what i'm saying
like
i always make dope hip-hop records i
feel i have a lot of gems from even back
in the day
but what that me monday's thing did is
like sharpen my sword and like i became
like
just a better songwriter you know what
i'm saying because now i'm forced
because i was creating a real time it's
not like i was sitting on 40 songs and i
i was creating a really good song every
week i was literally doing it because i
thought of the
concept like in december of like 20
whatever it was
in january i started you know what i'm
saying and um
so sometimes sunday night i'm still in
there trying to you know finishing up
the song yeah
and what it did is kind of you know i
was able to let go
of like overwrapping and like just you
know you can overwrap
you could definitely overwrap bro a lot
of lyricists do that especially when the
beats a little bit you know
yo i always say this there is a lot of
like
i do feel like there's um with with that
genre of hip-hop it can go left man
there's like a such thing
as like being too lyrical absolutely
absolutely i'm kind of like
like sometimes i'm not really a fan of
that no more if that if that makes sense
no i'm not
broke from from a lyricist you know what
i'm saying like
by the way there's people like at the
door i don't know if anyone can let them
in
they keep calling me i'm sorry uh barack
you want to go grab them and
this camera just shut off laura we can
edit this out
okay oh it's still running okay okay
yeah you could definitely be
be over lyrical you know what i'm saying
like and um
no i don't know it becomes kind of like
a backpack underground
almost corny kind of thing when you're
trying too hard you know what i'm saying
i feel like it's almost like acting
you'll see certain actors like
overacting you'll be like yo man it's
like
it's kind of whack like absolutely same
thing with rapping like i do feel like
you know uh without saying anyone's
names one of my friends just started
managing an artist and this artist is
from my hometown and is technically a
really good rapper
right like yeah you can rap but your
music is really hard to listen to
yeah and that that's what it comes down
to both things have to both things
should be true right like you could you
should be a good rapper but you also
want to
be listenable i always say like the
greats were always amazing rappers
of course this era previous eras the
great greats the goats like they can
[ __ ] rap
but it's all about the music at the end
of the day you know what i'm saying
and i feel like the music just has
become better and then another thing is
working with scott storch like he just
you know he just brings like he just
makes big records like
even when you listen to the nas one it's
hip-hop as [ __ ] but like it's a [ __ ]
record you know what i'm saying like
yeah and i think that that brought the
best out of me too like you know what
i'm saying like just the best
songwriting
even if you listen to this project with
burner like i'm [ __ ] rapping my ass
off on there but it's [ __ ] records on
there yeah i'm saying and we talking
about hustling and you know it's just
like a
relatable you know it's just not like
lyrical miracle [ __ ] you know i was
gonna say
because i remember coming up as a kid
like i used to just there was like an
era in my hip-hop life where i was so i
would like
put my nose up to anything that wasn't
like super [ __ ]
boom bap or like yeah like
yeah like you remember you know i like
those hip-hop snobs i would call them
yeah like ah if it wasn't talib quality
or [ __ ]
right you know or immortal technique or
some [ __ ]
like man that [ __ ] ain't real rap shout
out to immortal technique by the way too
yeah man i i agree i was like that too
i think we had a similar little era we
had a similar hip-hop kind of upbringing
yeah you and i like connect a lot on on
the type of [ __ ] we were listening to
that like i watch you do interviews and
[ __ ] and the things you say i'm like i
used to be like that too
yeah but like that's the thing though
hip-hop has evolved and like
artists have evolved and i've evolved
too you know what i'm saying
i was still about hip-hop and content
and
you know what i mean like that's what
i'm all about but [ __ ] good music you
know what i'm saying
um little known fact about armen
used to be a pharmacist yes now can you
aren't you always a pharmacist yeah i'm
a pharmacist i'm a licensed pharmacist
right now you know i'm saying i'm just
not working
you're not investigating a pharmacist uh
i own a couple pharmacies
at this point you know what i'm saying
so what i did is i guess that's kind of
like an armenian
immigrant type of thing you know what i
mean like how we raised
a lot of immigrants let me ask you this
is is the pharmacist
field is that something that a lot of
armenians get into
no i mean yes and no but i'm saying like
just to go into school
right got to be a doctor lawyer that
kind of upbringing you know what i'm
saying um
i feel like a lot of um a lot of
immigrant communities can relate like
you know your parents come from these
different countries where they usually
like fled from or whatever and come to
america for like a better
life or europe or whatever you know to
the western world
and then it gets pounded into your head
when you're a kid
like you know you got to go to school
even though they never went to school
you know what i'm saying
and that's kind of how i was brought up
you know what i'm saying like and then i
grew up in amsterdam i don't know if you
knew that like i was born in l.a
i was born in la i grew up in amsterdam
first 18 years of my life and then i
moved back to
oh [ __ ] yeah i'm like all multicultural
you know what i'm saying
and over there that's another thing like
if you live in a country like the
netherlands like everybody goes to
college like it's not like america where
like
i don't know 30 goes to college i'm just
throwing a number out
over there it's probably like 80 90
percent of kids go that's just part of
i don't know society right right right
so i i was kind of raised with that
mentality even though i'm
[ __ ] into music and i started doing
music a little bit in like
final years of high school then i moved
to l.a really wanted to do
music but i enrolled in college to even
move to l.a like i used school to kind
of like
a tool to move here you know what i'm
saying living off financially
and was your family in amsterdam when
you moved back to l.a yeah so i grew up
with my mom and my brother like my pops
passed when i was only one
um so my brother myself and my brother
we moved out here and then my mom
obviously followed you know what i'm
saying
so i ended up going to college ucla and
then
um in school i was always kind of
interested in like medical [ __ ] you know
what i mean
if i were to do even though i know it
doesn't make any sense like it wouldn't
help me in my music career
right but you know that there's always i
didn't really know what i'm doing
like you could always depend on a
medical degree because that [ __ ] ain't
going away for sure
and then you know just being like i said
like i'm the first in my community to do
this music thing too so there was like
no guidance like
at all you know what i'm saying like
you're just learning i didn't have an
older homie that had a cousin that was
i don't know an anr and you know what i
mean or like someone that was
dr dre's cousin or something like i had
no ties you know what i'm saying
so we were just young kids trying to
figure it out we meaning me and my you
know what i mean
and um meanwhile i'm going to school you
know i'm saying so i ended up going to
pharmacy school
really i was thinking of going to
medical school and then i'm like yo i
can't be a [ __ ] doctor and trying to
rap
you know what i'm saying so i kind of
bandwidth i kind of took the next best
thing
you know what i mean but it wasn't until
i was working as a pharmacist
i'm like yo i ain't trying to do this
bro you know what i'm saying and i'm
sure like having that money coming in
also probably helps with
so i find a dream yeah at first that's
what i did like i worked a couple years
and like whatever money i could
make i would you know shoot this video
let's do this let's do that and then it
became we got to a level where
my time and my dedication was more
important than a little bit of money
because you know you make a little bit
of money but
it's not as crazy as people think bro
you know what i'm saying like you live
in la if you run your own business
that's different but if you're just
working at like a rite aid
or cvs like i was doing yeah you make
good living like a decent so you have
your own pharmacies so now i got yeah we
got
a ventana pharmacy in tarzana so i'm
like a partner in in two pharmacies
that i just kind of like it's under my
license and i overlook it i don't i
don't
you know what i mean i don't work there
that's interesting dang
it's also being an independent artist
man you got to find ways to make money
and um you know we did a merch thing we
got a store yeah you got the pentagon in
glendale and you're going to lay
pentagon records is our label so the
store is the pentagon la
uh in glendale you know we started the
clothing line and then
you know these are all ways of just like
expanding you know what i mean the
hustle until
while working on the main thing you know
what i'm saying i want you to talk about
um because i before i moved to la i
didn't really know
any armenian people besides vic one
because i've known vic for a long long
time oh yeah me too shout out vic
and um you know moving to la like i live
in burbank
the glendale burbank oh yeah you live
among all the armenians yeah all my
neighbors armenian
thanks um and my god if y'all don't love
you some nice cars
yeah man you drive down glen oaks man
it's like g-wagons and
yeah and beamers and benzes boy like a
lot of times i meet people
like yo armenia's got money and it's
like armenians come from a third world
[ __ ] country
but we make money you know what i'm
saying like they come really like to
america to live the american dream
and whether it's like the school route
or the hustle route cause we kind of
heavy in both you know what i'm saying
also i feel like circulating the dollar
in the community
i've noticed you know what i mean
keeping that dollar in your own
community specifically like the newer
generation
like us and you know what i mean that's
what we focused on like just building
each other up supporting
and i'm sitting here because of like
like i said like burner and be reeling
them they had like armenian business
partners
and they were like yo you that do for us
you know what i'm saying like
so you know we kind of linked up and and
the resources became that much bigger
you know what i'm saying
well i wanted to ask you just because i
do feel like
there's uh when it comes to the armenian
community
i i i want some education on what's
going on right now
um i know there's some sort of there's
like a war going on
yeah i i don't know how to pronounce the
name of the other azerbaijan yeah
yeah can you kind of just educate people
what's going on there because i actually
posted something on
instagram which we appreciate
i'm so when i got jack last week the
witness was this little armenian kid
at wing stop and he was like yo they
look like they're armenians so i posted
two armenian or middle eastern people
right what [ __ ] is god at you and some
guy dm me
respectfully he did only one guy dm me
respectfully though
and he was like hey you should reword
that
right because people might think you're
so i did reword it
right but i didn't mean any like malice
and i obviously don't know what's going
on but he's like people might think
you're an agent of whatever that is
say that again azerbaijan yeah right so
it's like a little country uh right next
to like turkey
we was all part of the soviet union
before but the history goes far so i'll
try to say it real quick but if you
heard of the armenian genocide
which is not azerbaijan that's turkey so
turk the
modern-day turkey at the time it was i
wanted to get into that too because i
feel like a lot of people don't
understand
it's all kind of interconnected okay um
there was armenian genocide in 1915 so a
little more of a hundred years ago where
a million and a half armenians were
massacred
by turkey you know what i'm saying the
whole thing about it the reason why we
still protest and still talk about it i
started this whole movement about it
right called open wounds
um it's because to this day it hasn't
been recognized as a genocide so
basically they just
got away with killing a 1.5 million
people and history looks the other way
and history looks the other way and you
know if you know that the
the definition of genocide is like the
the planned
extermination or the systematic
extermination of a specific group of
people
and that's what was happening like the
holocaust of the jews or whatever you
know what i'm saying
so um to this day it hasn't been
recognized so there's always tension
between
you know turkey and armenia and
azerbaijan is like
allies with turkey like their kind of
brother and sister country okay
and there's other governments like the
united states that still haven't
recognized either
why because they're allies with turkey
too like
america we got army bases and things
like that because they have this
they have a perfect like entrance into
the middle east
you know i mean as far as like
geographically and america don't want to
lose that
so we need that you know what i'm saying
so it's a lot of political things behind
it obviously
but i mean 48 or 49 individual states
have recognized it mostly i just saw you
countries
there a new a new state just recognized
it uh
i think maybe search tankian might have
posted about it oh it could be serge
from system system of it down he's like
super like
he's a real activist he's like into this
yeah like he's like i kind of
systematize probably my second favorite
band ever
for sure and and i kind of followed in
their footsteps because we grew up on
them and they talked about the armenian
genocide and stuff in their
music and stuff and then that's kind of
how i started doing that in hip-hop you
know what i'm saying
but uh but yeah so going with all of
that there's always been like a tension
between these countries now
in azerbaijan there's a little piece of
land in the middle of the country
like all of it used to be armenia before
the genocide first of all you know what
i'm saying
and there's a little piece of country
that's like 95 percent armenian
populated uh but after the soviet union
broke
and everyone became independent the
soviet union decided to give that piece
of country
to azerbaijan instead of even though it
was armenian
that piece of land okay you know what
i'm saying so it's been a war
over that piece of land for like [ __ ]
years decades now
but it's always like coming and going
the main issue now these last few weeks
that it became a big thing because i
guess it was a ceasefire and it's a
middle of a pandemic and all that [ __ ]
but even though there was a ceasefire
they just broke it and they just
attacked not only military targets but
civilian targets like out of nowhere
you know what i'm saying and that was
the whole thing now like yo what's
happening you know what i'm saying
so that's going on going on right now
yeah right now
damn you know that that part of the
world is
is crazy you know what i'm saying i was
about to ask you like
you know i feel like
especially you know when you think of
like uh
israel and palestine and it's almost
like
is that kind of like if you met someone
who was turkish right
it's like there's automatically just
like it's
it's pretty sad because you know like i
said i grew up in amsterdam if you know
anything about netherlands and europe
mad turkish people it's mad middle
eastern people right
but predominantly in like harlem germany
france turkish people i grew up with mad
turkish people
i turkish i was going to ask you like
yeah that's kind of personally i did
but most armenians because they never
really
you know the only thing we grew up with
learning about turkey is
the enemy which is i mean look in in the
newer generation we don't really think
like that anymore
i feel like that's kind of the case yeah
we don't feed hate anymore
right what i'm saying we actually blame
countries like azerbaijan and them for
raising their kids
like we an enemy for some reason so that
country and
they literally have that like matt clips
was going around these last few weeks of
like school and
people teaching you know so in that
country they're literally indoctrinating
these kids to hate armenian people
we don't do that i i like to say as much
anymore but inside
i mean that tension is always there for
sure that's crazy i mean think about it
if a million and a half people were
murdered like
a lot of our grandparents their entire
families got wiped out
you know what i'm saying but no one ever
paid the price so it's like a chip on
your [ __ ] shoulder this was 1918
right 1915
1915 okay 19 like 17 or 18. damn dude
yeah that's crazy i saw that uh there's
a movie that's coming out called a
promise with uh christian bale
yeah that came out a couple years ago
but it's coming out on netflix right now
okay i saw it actually it should be
about it i think it's this week it's on
netflix now and that's about the
genocide that's about the army and
genocide yep
that's the first time a big movie was
made about it too we went to the
premiere
kim kardashian was there i got my
picture you got your kim picture no i'm
saying that she went super viral
you post anything with kim you get mad
it's for no reason
do you feel like the the kardashians uh
are there for the
because obviously their dad was armenian
um they are okay
they they always speak about it the
armenian community loves them for that
you know what i'm saying because i mean
just using your platform and obviously
their [ __ ] platform is so big
they talk about it a lot all of them do
you feel some sort of responsibility
being like someone who grew up in
amsterdam and obviously the hip-hop
community is such a
at least now i feel like just some it's
like a safe place for everybody
i guess you know like i'm bringing
everybody together to try to like
you know i guess as a leader of like
your community do you feel like any
pressure to try to like
bring bring people together or break
down any sort of stereotypes people
might have or
like anything like that so that's a good
that's a good question like i feel like
i always talked about these type of
issues because hip-hop being like the
voice of the voiceless the voice of the
people
just originally as a genre me coming in
from like a new
you know ethnicity into the game i had
to like represent or tell the story of
my people yeah honestly i didn't
i didn't know i mean honestly i knew
based because i
was like yo the you know your your uh
brand your shirt
our wounds are still open yeah that i i
just
that's that's how i figured out what was
going on and then we have some
some members of our staff at the station
who are armenian that kind of kind of
gave me up about the genocide and i was
like damn i had no [ __ ] idea
yeah that [ __ ] um i could probably say
like i did a lot of damage because i did
basically i just did one song about it
i always say it's really a song about
crimes against humanity but specifically
i'm talking about the armenian genocide
it's called opal wounds and then we did
these t-shirts
you know what i'm saying with our wounds
it just says our wounds are still open
1915.
and you know we just did that to like i
wore it in a video and we had a few
printed it wasn't like a thing we
thought of you know what i mean
but then everyone started asking about
those t-shirts and every time i was
wearing it
every single day someone would stop me
and say what does that mean
for some reason it's really like a dope
design and it catches people's attention
and um we realized like yo this is like
a
a tool to like create you know raise
awareness and educate people
kind of in a way never been done it's
kind of like a dope fresh new way using
hip hop and fashion
so then we started printing those shirts
and giving them to as many influencers
as we could yeah man
and like game was definitely the first
person i mean he lived in glendale too
so i was gonna say game used to live in
glendale yeah so he'd been around
armenia so he he knew the struggle and
he knew so he embraced it right away he
posted it and then he jumped on the
remix of the song you know
fire shout out the game but then after
that so many people you know we got
cardi
we got post we got met the man wearing
there is there any eggs we got
as far as what's going on in your
country right now is there any way
people can like
i i guess i don't know is there any sort
of way like people can help or
yeah for sure spread awareness i always
say there's like
two ways you can help obviously spread
awareness like we
we'd love for other you know races and
people
i never even heard of that other country
that's what's crazy right and everything
it must be very small it's a small
country i mean armenia being small i
think
azerbaijan is even smaller right if i'm
not mistaken yeah
so it's it's a super small country and
it's it sucks because you guys are from
the same part of the
like the main thing about armenians is
we originally christian right
um armenians are actually the first
christian nation in the whole world like
officially
adopted christianity and like the year
301 you know i mean like the first
christian nation in the world
everyone surrounding it is like pretty
extreme muslim it's
iran it's turkey so it's always been
religion
history it's always been a religious
thing yeah religion is a [ __ ]
ain't it sure
that [ __ ] is crazy to think like that is
like
it's crazy that that's probably the
reason of all the most wars and i think
i mean i think at the root of them
probably all of them
like every single war that's wild
there's religion wrapped up in there
somewhere
it's [ __ ] insane are you a pretty
religious guy i'm pretty real i mean i'm
definitely spiritual
spiritual i think there's i definitely
consider myself a christian
you're christian okay the difference is
i guess i am part of a church
i you know i don't go every week or you
know what i mean what you believe
but i believe yeah i believe there's
some something controlling all of this
you know
that's wild man shout out to uh to uh
you man for
for for doing your thing and uh the
album with burner
join album with burner it's called the
warning and
you got big features on there styles p's
on there dave eastwiz
be real and my boy chris webby shout out
to chris webby by the way
my dog a.d shout out to
and also shout out to a.d.'s teeth who
need their own instagram
brand new i remember he got them
chompers
yes he do shout out a.d he'll [ __ ] up a
corn on the cob
that's my friend he's my boy he's my boy
yeah every time i see him i say the same
that's my brother too shout out
shout out all the all the features came
really organically like
you know burner obviously he has a super
crazy network
but i made it a point that like i wasn't
gonna bother burner because he's already
given me a bigger look by doing this
project women oh yeah
i was going to hit up burner like yo can
we get this person can we get you know
what i'm saying so
all the features basically i got off my
strength
obviously saying it's an army and burner
album um i did hit him up for
dave east because we met dave i met
davey's first time when i was on tour
with burner in new york
we got to sold out sobs and i got off
stage
uh right before bernie was going to go
on i walked into the green room and yeah
it was dave east you know what i'm
saying
and he just you know just briefly we
said what's up but that's when it
clicked like we had that record on god
and i was like yo i need dave east on
there so that's the only one when i hit
burner i'm like yo
let's get davies on this one he
connected me whatever i went to the
studio with him
burner wasn't there but all the other
ones even whiz
be real was already my my man and then
styles p which
kind of happened in a really dope way
because i didn't even know style speed
knew who the [ __ ] i was
but apparently he was [ __ ] with me
you know what i'm saying and later in
the studio he said sway put me onto you
you dead nice and
you know when those legends like the
goats show you love like that
like that's that means a lot to me is
this gonna be the because i i feel like
you've been
uh kind of low-key the last couple of
years
i've been stacking up music yeah is this
going to be like what kicks off the
floodgate of a whole lot of
armenian this is it baby we're here now
because we just had a discussion the
other day i was like man like now you
gotta like you gotta
like you gotta get on your campaign [ __ ]
like you know you can't just drop this
and then go away for a year of course no
of course no that's how we've been
planning it you know what i'm saying
like i've just been locked in
putting your ducks last couple years
because everything needed to just
elevate you know what i'm saying and
like just from the production to the
everything down to the artwork to just
the way the team's moving
um everything's been [ __ ] amazing now
it's next level and it's starting off
with this burner album
and you know you've seen it obviously we
dropped the first single then we dropped
the video oh it's been doing great man
i've been looking at i mean i followed
you on spotify so you know
your ship pops up all the time and like
yo you're killing it on spotify man
yeah just [ __ ] everything just god i
mean music is great
it's great dude i think like i think
you're uh
evolving as an artist because i remember
when i i think i don't remember who who
brought you onto the the show at first
was it nico blitz who set that up
it was remember who tommy is tommy he
was on the camera
[ __ ] top boy tom that [ __ ] guy
because you if you were were you new and
i
just started because he told me bootleg
kev and you know we're doing this
freestyle thing but i guess you hadn't
really done any
like now it's obviously a thing with you
and head right head wasn't even part
when it was me and damage and dre
sinatra exactly so i just pulled up
he called me like pull up right now
unprepared whatever i'm thinking like
i'm just paying for like whatever
and then i realized okay this is like a
real thing you know what i'm saying so i
got to come back
because i don't think we ever it wasn't
even being released on youtube yet at
the time we just did it
yeah i think what happened was i think
that
i don't remember how the freestyle came
out but i think you didn't feel good
about the freestyle
and i don't think we were like i think
we were like i think
we had just started it so we were like
you know what let's not even drop this
one because i feel like you were and you
you hadn't dropped any before either it
was super early um but yeah no we gotta
do so i was like
then when you and had really started
going in on it i mean i might start a
freestyle thing from here because we're
not even allowed to have people come to
the station anymore i know
the station's shut down i know like
fully so that's why i'm starting this
i was already thinking like i might
start
that'd be dope yeah usually i would do
all of that now because it's album time
and [ __ ] let's do it
let's do it next week let's do it you
got some [ __ ] ready
i come through next week oh it's fire
but yeah no ready
but no i was gonna say bro like i do
feel like
when i first heard your [ __ ] i was like
i think i i heard a couple of songs
that i just like looked up right and i
was like yo this dude can rap
yeah but i was like i don't know i just
don't know if i'd listen to him
like because he's like fire like yeah he
could rap but i feel like
no i i know stuff that's how i stuff you
personally like the stuff you've played
me like and then just the stuff that's
already come out like i'm like yo this
dude is like you're growing into a dope
artist man and so
appreciate it just don't let up man
appreciate it nah man we're just getting
started come on
our mean the album is out officially now
it's called the warning like we said wiz
khalifa on there be real styles p
davies the singles couple singles that
we dropped already doing crazy so
and if you need medicine go to his
pharmacy in tarzana
yeah but don't hit me you know don't hit
him for no weirdo [ __ ]
you better go in there i never talked
about it oh okay okay because yeah i'm
sorry
we just blew up his spot everyone gonna
hit him like you know i need somebody
you know saying so all the rappers be
hitting me tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves everybody chill
yeah yeah no come grab some gear
at the penny yeah go get some gear at
the pentagon and uh
and that's a that's in glendale and um
yeah get the album man
oh and shout out to odd socks oh we got
to do the odd socks love
yo our new sponsor odd socks oh yeah
i'll [ __ ] with some good
throw me some socks over here make sure
you go to oddssocksofficial.com
jesus christ oh my god look at these
these are the uh the walter whites the
breaking bads oh [ __ ] okay the ninja
turtles
anyway oddssocksofficial.com the most
comfortable socks in the world
and use the key uh keyword bootleg cab
for 20
off cold stone austin did you say cold
stone
austin it's stone cold don't call it
i like gorgeous people don't know it's
mad early right now marie austin
official.com bam